à paul on l'a vu plus tôt mène une
bataille contre le fbi a aimé
l'entreprise fait aussi face à de la
résistance de la part des citoyens et
des états comme les autres géants du web
d'ailleurs google facebook amazon
les quatre ans les surnomme le gafa bon
sens là dessus en semaine il ya de plus
en plus d'événements en fait qui montre
qu'on les laisse plus tout à fait agir à
leur guise et il ya un cas assez célèbre
qui porte sur un tableau tout aussi
célèbre actuelle week en colère va
regarder un extrait de ce reportage que
j'avais fait il ya quelques années sur
l'origine du monde
les glissières ne seront plus tiré que
devant de rares élus dans des
circonstances exceptionnelles
jusqu'à ce que les héritiers de lacan en
face dont elle est à l'origine du monde
entre alors au musée d'orsay
l'origine du monde donc tableaux
célèbres un cachet longtemps oui un sexe
qui plus d'un siècle après sa création
fait encore trembler les grands de ce
monde
facebook dont depuis cinq ans est en
cours quand on est en haut de française
frédéric durand cet internaute club
poursuit facebook parce que facebook
avait suspendu son compte il ya cinq ans
parce qu'il avait mis en ligne une photo
de cette peinture l'oeil facebook si
vous n'avez pas le droit selon nos
conditions d'utilisation et donc
facebook refusé d'être jugé selon les
lois françaises
hélas la semaine dernière la cour
d'appel de paris a reconnu que facebook
devaient être jugés selon les lois
françaises alors ça c'est quand même
quelque chose qui pourrait être lourd de
conséquences pour toutes sortes d'autres
compagnies américaines compagnie du
numérique qui font qu'ils oeuvrent en
europe et plus particulièrement en
france alors ce sera à suivre
mais il ya aussi que la question des
profits de ces grands groupes numérique
qui pose problème
oui absolument au mois de novembre le
sénat français a voté un amendement au
projet de loi sur les finances qui est
un peu l'équivalent de ce que les
britanniques ont appelé la taxe gogo on
se rappelle que les britanniques l'an
dernier ont appris avec horreur que
facebook avait payé la somme de 5000
livres sterling en impôt sur les
sociétés ces dix mille dollars et en
france on estime donc les peaux qui
échappe à l'état français dont qui part
dans les paradis fiscaux c'est environ 4
milliards d'euros
pour la simple années de la seule année
2012 donc c'est énorme ça pourrait avoir
des conséquences quand même assez gros
cet amendement d'elle cet amendement
la qui a été voté donc au mois de
novembre et puis l'un finalement c'est
l'inde qui s'est démarqué en interdisant
un service gratuit offert par facebook à
fruits bge x le service donc été annulé
on l'interdît en haine ce qui s'est
passé c'est que en fait free baiser que
c'était une initiative que certains
jugent est bonne de facebook c'est à
dire d'offrir du web à des populations
qui sont trop pauvres pour donc
s'inscrire pour aller naviguer
sauf que c'est facebook qui décident est
des sites que les gens allaient voir et
ça ça entre en collision frontale avec
les principes de neutralité du web c'est
à dire que tous les internautes ont
droit d'avoir accès à tous les sites qui
le désire peut importe leur statut
financier est donc un des membres du
conseil d'administration facebook mark
induit censé faire ramasser la semaine
dernière parce qu'il a publié un tweet
elodie l'anticolonialisme a été
économiquement catastrophique pendant
des décennies pour les indiens pourquoi
s'arrêter maintenant
alors en fait c'est lui qu'on a accusés
d'agir comme le dirigeant d'un empire
néocolonial bref on commence beaucoup à
s'élever contre la toute-puissance de
ces géants là et ça c'est un peu partout
dans le monde
voilà alors on va surveiller ça me la
suis fait plaisir